chargeurs apple seront bientôt interdits
par l'union européenne qui va imposer le
chargeur universel on t'explique
pourquoi et à partir de quand cette
mesure sera appliquée en fait l'ue a
décidé d'imposer un chargeur filaire
universel pour tous les appareils
électroniques portables de petite et de
moyenne taille en gros ça concerne les
tablettes les consoles les appareils
photo les liseuses les écouteurs les
casques les enceintes et donc les
smartphones la réglementation est claire
si ces appareils se recharge à bien
capillaire ils devront être équipés d'un
port usb type c quel que soit le
fabricant ce texte rend furieux apple
qui utilise la technologie de charge
lightning sont plus d'un milliard
d'appareils d'hambourg l'entreprise
américaine a vivement critiqué le texte
européen estimant qu'il est tout frais
l'innovation la commission européenne
qui tentait elle d'imposer cette
réglementation depuis 2009 avance des
arguments économiques et
environnementaux elle estime que le
texte permettra aux consommateurs
européens d'économiser 250 millions
d'euros par an et réduira les déchets
des chargeurs non utilisées de presque
1000 tonnes temps la mesure devra être
appliquée à partir de l'automne 2024 a
indiqué le parlement européen